and get two months free.
>> Tucker: NOT JUST NFL
PLAYERS, A MEMBER OF THE
STAND AGAINST THE AMERICAN
FLAG AS AN ACT OF PROTEST,
HE SAYS.
REPRESENTATIVE BRUCE FRANKS
RAISED HIS RIGHT HAND WITH A
CLINCHED FIST DURING THE
POLICEMEN OF THE OPENING DAY
OF THE 2018 LEGISLATIVE
SESSION.
HE SAYS HE PREFERS TO QUOTE
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
US TONIGHT.
FROM
MROM
MR. FRANKS, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> YOU HAVE A SWEATSHIRT ON
THAT SAYS I'M ROUTING FOR
EVERYBODY BLACK.
WHAT IF I HAD A SWEATSHIRT
THAT SAYS I'M ROUTING FOR
EVERYBODY WHITE.
>> I WOULDN'T BE UPSET ABOUT
AGAINST EVERYBODY BLACK.
>> YOU RAISED A FIST IN I
GUESS DEFIANCE?
TELL US WHAT THIS SYMBOLIC
ACT MEANT.
WHAT DID YOU MEAN BY IT
DURING THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE?
>> SO I HAVE NEVER SAID THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
AND EVEN IN THE HOUSE LAST
YEAR WHEN I WAS IN SESSION,
MOST OF THE TIME I WASN'T IN
THE CHAMBERS BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT, YOU KNOW HAVE A
LOT OF RESPECT AND FEEL
PROUDLY ABOUT THE FLAG AND
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I KNOW HOW I FEEL.
AND SO MY RAISING MY FIST
WAS BASICALLY POWER TO THE
PEOPLE, TO ALL PEOPLE.
ALL POWER TO THE PEOPLE
VESTED INTO THE PEOPLE.
WHEN I SAY APLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHO I'M ELECTED TO
THAT'S WHO I STAND FOR.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, GOOD FOR
YOU.
I THINK YOU WERE ELECTED BY
THE PEOPLE AND YOU OUGHT TO
REPRESENT THEM.
WHEN YOU HAVE SAY YOU KNOW
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
>> SO WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE, THE
THING THAT STICKS OUT MOST
IS WHEN I HEAR FOR LIBERTY
FOR ALL, WE OBVIOUSLY
HAVEN'T SEEN THAT ACROSS THE
WE SEE THAT THERE ARE --
WHEN IT COMES TO JUSTICE,
THAT LOOKS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT, DEPENDING ON
SOMETIMES WHERE YOU'RE FROM.
DEPENDING ON SOMETIMES WHAT
YOUR SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS
IS.
AND WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
BUT SO DOES THAT MEAN YOU
ARE AGAINST THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BECAUSE IT HOLDS
THOSE UP AS IDEALS?
I'M CONFUSED.
>> I UNDERSTAND THEY HOLD
THOSE UP.
MY THING IS WE TALK ABOUT
WE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE AND
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
THE COUNTRY?
AREN'T THE PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY KIND OF THE SAME
FEEL WHICH IS WHY I'M ASKING
YOU BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU
ARE OPPOSED TO AMERICA WHEN
YOU TAKE A STAND AGAINST THE
FLAG AND PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE, BUT MAYBE THAT'S
NOT YOUR POSITION?
>> I'M OPPOSED TO FOLKS IN
ECONOMICALLY STRESSED
COMMUNITIES BEING TREATED
DIFFERENTIALLY IN AMERICA.
I AM OPPOSED TO THE WAY OUR
ECONOMICALLY DISTRESSED
COMMUNITIES, OUR
MARGINALIZED PEOPLE IN
AMERICA.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF VETERANS
MATTER WHAT THAT IS, EVEN IF
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
AGREE.
MANY OF THEM HAVE EXPRESSED
TO ME THAT THIS IS THE VERY
REASON WHY THEY FOUGHT.
THEY FOUGHT FOR OUR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT.
AND WE ARE NOT ALWAYS GOING
TO AGREE ON WHEN WE EXERCISE
THEM OR WHAT WE'RE
EXERCISING THEM ABOUT.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> BUT IT'S OUR RIGHT TO
EXERCISE THEM.
>> Tucker: YOU WON'T FIND
THAT CONTESTED HERE AND I
AGREE WITH YOU ACTUALLY THAT
I WANT TO ASK YOU ONE LAST
QUESTION, YOU MADE NEWS
RECENTLY WHEN LEAR
RECENTLY WHEN LYRR
RECENTLY WHEN LYRICS THAT
YOU WROTE AS A SEMI
PROFESSIONAL RAP ARTIST
BEFORE YOU WERE ELECTED CAME
OUT TALKED ABOUT KILLING
SNITCHES.
THAT SEEMED LIKE SOMETHING
MAYBE YOU WOULD WANT TO
REPUDIATE.
YOU WOULD WANT TO SAY BOY,
I'M SORRY I SUGGESTED IT WAS
A GOOD IDEA TO, QUOTE, KILL
SNITCHES.
WHAT'S YOUR POSITION ON
THAT?
>> SO MY POSITION IS FOR
ONE, WE OFTEN HEAR ABOUT MY
OLD LYRICS, BUT THEY DON'T
PAY ATTENTION TO THE NEW
LYRICS.
THEY DON'T PAY ATTENTION TO
THE NEW DISTANCES.
THAT WAS AT A TIME WHEN I
WAS AN ARTIST.
I WAS USING MY ART -- I WAS
USING MY ASIMPLIES AND
METAPHORS AS WE DO IN RAP.
AS WE'RE TALKING NINE YEARS
AGO.
AND A GREAT MAN SAID DON'T
BE SO QUICK TO COB ITEM
THOSE WHO DON'T DO AS YOU DO
OR SAY AS YOU SAY AS QUICK.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN YOU
DON'T DO THE SAME THINGS --
DO THE SAME THINGS THAT YOU
DO NOW.
>> Tucker: ALL RIGHT.
>> I WOULD LIKE FOR PEOPLE
TO PAY ATTENTION TO THE
CURRENT SITUATION AND THE
FIGHT THAT WE ARE PUTTING UP
AND THE DISTANCES THAT WE
ARE TAKING RATHER THAN OLD